three Eastern partners take big steps
towards closer ties with the European
Union on June 27th as EU leaders sign
association agreements with Ukraine
Georgia and Moldova the signatures come
much earlier than originally envisioned
move forward to underline the EU s
commitment and support to the Eastern
partners as President Van Rompuy noted
on his visit to Tbilisi in May choosing
the path of political association market
integration with the European Union
should not be seen as a rejection of
close relationships with other partners
it should not be seen as a zero-sum game
these Accords strengthen both political
and economic ties between Brussels and
the three capitals they include the
creation of deep and comprehensive free
trade areas opening new avenues for
trade and business they also aim to
improve cooperation on the rule of law
judicial reform respect for human rights
and other democratic values for Georgia
and Moldova the agreements will be
signed in their entirety an event
President Van Rompuy said could not be
underestimated it is a dream for
generations of people of Georgia and
Moldova and this dream comes true
now the government of Ukraine will be
completing those portions of its
agreement that remain after political
provisions were signed in March this is
the Accord that sent Ukrainians in to
Maidan square last year to stand up for
their convictions and that triggered the
crisis where so many died now their
aspirations for a more European future
are being realized